our series of more perfect unions shows
that what unites us
as americans is far greater than what
divides us and this morning we are
highlighting four sisters on a mission
to end
racial injustice with a simple recipe a
literal one
like so many americans the loftman
siblings found themselves baking
while in lockdown at their family's new
jersey home
they've been making a traditional jewish
bread and loads of it
nikki bates shows us how that's raising
money to help
organizations all across the country
fight for social justice
the four loftman sisters didn't expect
to find themselves where they started as
little girls
in their parents kitchen baking challah
a jewish bread
we fall into that group of jews who
learned how to bake challah when we were
really young it's
eaten ceremonially on the sabbath friday
evening
when the pandemic pushed college classes
and jobs online
marnie sarah and hannah headed home to
teaneck new jersey
to spend time with their parents and
youngest sister eliana
chala has its own symbolism it's
traditionally a braided bread
so with each strand of bread we're kind
of reminded that
we're all unified and that we're all
connected
somewhere somehow initially the sisters
decided to donate loaves to front line
workers in their hometown
but a few weeks later news of george
floyd's death sparked a second idea we
want freedom for all black and oppressed
people
we all attended the four of us the black
lives matter protest that took place in
teaneck
and that was a really pivotal moment for
us the holla back girls were born
the sisters began selling lows of their
chala and donating profits
two different organizations committed to
racial equity
and social justice this really was a
project that was inspired by the moment
because we were home because
there was this attention to all these
different issues
when we're actively baking the challah
there's a traditional blessing that we
say called the hafris
what's happening when i do that blessing
i try to think of the people around the
world who need that healing and who need
that
that prayer so far the hullaback girls
have given away nearly fifty thousand
dollars to fourteen organizations
including the b3 foundation a non-profit
providing
educational tools and scholarships to
under-resourced
children it was founded by pittsburgh
steeler zack banner he posted this video
tasting the sisters challah that is fire
it's literally a group of sisters baking
and
and working and sweating and doing all
these things
for a good cause but it was it's just
such a small gesture
it's so easy to do how many states have
you now
sent your holo to we're at 42
states wow and over 300 cities
this is zach banner's favorite spreading
a love of challah
one loaf at a time it was dangerously
good
for cbs this morning i'm nikki batiste
in teaneck new jersey
the perfect shade of brown rays the way
it
imagine it hot with some butter on it
olive french toast hollywood peanut
butter and banana
little honey nice job sisters very nice
job
yeah love it well we can get you some
you know they're telling
us i'm going to make a call to somebody